hey everybody this is Eric Nam and I'm
doing 30 questions in three minutes
that's impossible because I talk at
great lengths and I just ramble so good
luck setting me up for failure but what
happens if I don't get it so I get like
slapped in the face you're like hit me
talking hey [ __ ] you it's my favorite
don't laugh at me oh that's so deep nice
happy generous Midnight in Paris Korean
a piano Bruno Mars where I have like
crazy facial hair myself it's like the
hard eyes with a smiley face my computer
my phone and my wallet so practical rats
oh I hate rats I deal first day is like
a chilled dinner at a nice cozy
restaurant with a lot of wine
it's a photo of who's Lisbon Portugal a
house flying you sexy I'm sexy it's my
song like 20 minutes
people who talk too much like me but our
new album if you've really disappointed
I love you amber
pepperoni if they take care of
themselves that's very general but very
an important statement just think about
it um they're different guys do you have
your mom or dad you love them all
equally except one a little bit more
than the other not this one did I really
make it under three minutes you were
like really slow okay thank you so much
for having me on 30 questions in three
minutes that was really stressful next
time I want more intense questions I
just released a new album that's called
before we begin and the lead single off
of it is called congratulations
featuring Marquis BC so please check it
out the music videos super dope and I'll
probably be in a city near you very soon
on tour love you guys bye sorry amber
[Music]